An einer stark befahrenen Kreuzung
in München-Schwabing steht er:
der denkmalgeschützte Hochbunker
aus der Nazizeit.
1943 gebaut, sollte er gut 700 Menschen
bei Bombenangriffen Schutz bieten.
Heute ist er einer der
ungewöhnlichsten Wohnorte Münchens.
Hallo, mein Name ist Stefan Höglmaier.
Ich zeige Ihnen jetzt den Bunker.
Stefan Höglmaier wohnt
ganz oben im Bunker.
Über drei Etagen und rund
400 Quadratmeter
erstreckt sich die Wohnung
des Immobilienentwicklers.
Der Einrichtungsstil nimmt Anleihen
aus vielen Epochen.
Die harten Formen des Bunkers
kontrastieren mit verspielten Elementen.
Stefan Höglmaier hat die originale Struktur
des Gebäudes an vielen Stellen bewusst
offengelegt. Als ich das Gebäude zum
ersten Mal begangen hab‘,
war [das] schon sehr bedrückend:
zwei Meter dicke Wände
und null Außenraumbezug
und das eben über alle Stockwerke,
also über sieben Stockwerke.
Und dann … das is [ist] etwas, was
[man] natürlich so nicht kennt, weil
wenn man sonst in ein Gebäude reingeht,
irgendwann hat man dann mal Licht,
Luft, Ausblick.
Um diesen Bezug zur Außenwelt zu schaffen,
ließ er in jede Wand ein Fenster schneiden,
vier Fenster pro Stockwerk.
Als Stefan Höglmaier das Gebäude 2010
erwarb, sah der Bunker noch so aus.
Vierzehn Arbeiter waren fast
sieben Monate damit beschäftigt,
die Öffnungen in den zwei Meter
dicken Beton zu schneiden.
2000 Tonnen Beton haben wir hier
rausgenommen, also das heißt,
diese Öffnungen, die wir
hier geschaffen haben,
[sind] insgesamt ungefähr
das Gewicht von 2000 PKWs.
Und das war durchaus
eine bauliche Herausforderung.
Aber ich glaube, es war nicht
nur die bauliche Herausforderung,
sondern auch überhaupt das
Thema, wie man sich dem nähert:
‘n Gebäude aus der Nazizeit umzunutzen
und eben dann auch bewohnbar zu machen,
zur Geschichte einen Bezug herzustellen,
die Geschichte nicht zu verwischen,
also lesbar zu lassen,
Spuren sichtbar zu lassen
und aber trotzdem auch natürlich
Wohnlichkeit herzustellen,
dass es funktioniert.
Eine Treppe führt in die
neugebaute oberste Etage.
Auch für das Penthouse musste ein Loch in
den meterdicken Beton geschnitten werden.
So, jetzt sind wir dann
final über dem Bunker.
[Hier] hat man [einen]
gigantischen Ausblick.
Hier ist jetzt erst
mal der Essplatz, und
im Weiteren ist dann
hier das Wohnzimmer,
was im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes lichtdurchflutet ist.
Man hat hier den Nordfriedhof
mit einem Meer von Bäumen,
der mit dem Englischen
Garten verschmilzt,
und bei schönem Wetter
sieht man bis zu den Alpen.
Die Dachterrasse des Penthouses
bietet einen 360-Grad-Blick auf München.
Um seinen bayrischen Wurzeln
treu zu bleiben,
gibt es bei Stefan Höglmaier sogar
eine Outdoor-Stube aus Zirbelholz.
So kann man wind- und
sonnengeschützt draußen sitzen.
Stefan Höglmaier hat mit seiner Firma
für rund fünf Millionen Euro
den Bunker in ein hochmodernes
Gebäude verwandelt.
In dem 26 Meter hohen Turm gibt es
nicht nur weitere Wohnungen und Büros,
sondern auch eine Galerie
namens „B´NK´R“ – „Bunker“.
Hier finden regelmäßig Ausstellungen mit
Schwerpunkt Kunst und Architektur statt,
öffentlich zugänglich und kostenlos.
Eine echte Herzensangelegenheit
von Stefan Höglmaier.
Der Bunker stand hier
jahrzehntelang im Stadtraum.
Ganz stark wahrnehmbar irgendwie
als Schreckgespenst.
Und ja, ich finde es eben ganz wichtig, dass
die Bevölkerung es weiterhin erfahren kann
und eben jetzt auch leben kann,
wie das Gebäude befriedet wurde.
Wohnen im Hochbunker.
Mit viel Liebe und Engagement
wurde aus einem Münchner
Schreckens - ein Vorzeigeobjekt.